[Music]
every time an okay so it's a little bit
embarrassing but my buildings pre-world
were wanting it plumbing say no more
that's accessories dope dude thank you
great seeing you you too Hal I me huh
hey dude I'm in the middle of trying to
find this thing at B B&B hold up you're
at me being BRD give me six feet me that
place where that Judi connects condoms
stat why I was gonna say stuff to you
oh dude what is all of this
welcome to she work we are officially
open for schist miss what is she worked
she worked as an inclusive work
environment that caters to smokers I see
a bunch of new pens trash furniture and
two people smoking cigarettes walk with
me
so she uses the urban landscape for a
fast-paced workspace with no boundaries
huh if parkour is using the city as your
gym she work is using the cities your
office so correct me if I'm wrong people
are paying you to use the free public
charging station so what all the great
male entrepreneurs do it okay they take
something that already exists claim it
was their idea
throw in some fancy furniture and
charged double for it for letting people
sit on your junk and smoke exactly wait
on that farmer huh I'm sorry
smoking Secrets is disgusting okay
Smokey's sobs hey nuts but who am I to
judge a nicotine addiction
I mean I'm fully addicted to eat true
okay you got the stuff I thank you bitch
come on come on come on come on thank
you so much and actually a trash can is
the only thing we don't need here at you
er no no this is actually mine on my
ship I'll get itself come again it's my
bucket
I make my I had to get a bucket who
what how when where and why he's bunny
sorry you know how my toilet is always
getting clogged so Fernando actually let
me know that I can't flush twin the
paper anymore and actually have to
discard it in a separate bin right next
to the toilet so what just hit him so
then I said I said sit Fernando I will
get that bucket so I said and I got
I got one dude I was like I was standing
here and I was just like so stunned by
what was going on I got bullied into
buying a bucket you know and I
think we should take this issue into the
community action wing if she were now is
there hold come on okay so we have to
review our resources okay the printer
scanner so there's a scanning function
what you're gonna do is scan your tits
spray your ass make a ton of copies
disseminate them to all your neighbors
but get this anonymously everybody's
like what's going on whose tits are this
me Ron you've planted a stack of the
tits and Fernando's office and you pipe
up and you say you know I think it might
be Fernando and while we're on the topic
why are we in buckets
she work oh dude you are so close alone
okay what if I print out my petition
okay to go around my neighbors and like
guys this is an important issue who
should be buckets okay I
get the full signed petition take it
back to Fernando and I'm like majority
rules man
changes come in oh you are full-blown
grassroots see where the call X on jail
cause Neil Court has of a story on your
the Jewish shirley chisholm toilets yes
I am gonna my toilet and flush yes
don't get your bucket and take care of
come on yeah I love she work this
time are you sick of being treated like
a filthy outsider at work because of
your tragic smoking habit
how's that Wi-Fi working ll hahaha
charging station guest is coming in
clear as day you know we are growing
rapidly and I'm starting stuff to focus
on expansion so would you feel
comfortable watching the fort was asking
hello my name is Abbi Abrams don't water
bye
and he Girl Scout cookies know I'm not a
Girl Scout anymore I'm a grown I'm
actually your neighbor I'm just going
around letting everyone know that I'm
having a tenant meeting today in the
lobby I have lived in this building for
31 years and I've never seen you wait
are you Melody's roommate you know
melody yes she dates that wonderful
young man who always brings me delicious
cheese's that's um that's Bevers they're
the loveliest I love them as well
[Music]